Michael Fabiano with our brother nfl.com
senior fanta senior analyze getting gray
on the side and as you know what you're
talking about and I said don't bring me
in any any any chunks I only talked to
senior people when it comes to fantasy
because you know what I consider myself
a senior person yeah last year you you
know I text you ask you questions what
do you think we participated in in the
Jerry Cantrell and charity day I have a
trade - and is great bid trade I felt
like that was you you kind of rookies me
but you know what that's fine that's
fine you didn't win the league did you
you know I should have won another that
should I lost from the playoffs because
Scott Ian started the Falcons defense
against the Rams and they had like 20
points and I believe Rich Eisen didn't
win the league either now Jerry wanted
okay
yeah Jerry wanted okay I don't even know
why Richard I made the finals I don't
know how you two guys did right oh wait
we can you I drafted that team but what
is that it's a mission where the only
reason were rich - man you got a GM rich
imitate him it is him the fact that it
was a charity League it's okay no no no
no it's okay you don't have a GED right
you have a GM not anymore
okay you know my history I haven't she
had with my son yeah and his friend but
those we party wait you can't have a GM
you got to run it yourself
I agree by the way what's going on with
the stern League man I just want to
point out you having a question he had
animals at the stern show like do you
bring around bring enough people want to
know I want to know what happened is
just what happened last year okay
I was winning the league by 300 points
300 that's what you call three on a
point we can't get Lance manifold
sucking ass that's what that's called
domination yeah that's pretty good man
300 points 300 points when you're in
first place 300 points okay I beat
everybody at least once some of them
twice mmm does that dunkey at what does
that dunkey can you get to the playoffs
and then Julio and Melvin
Gordon got hurt oh yeah I was
undermanned it's fine I won the draft I
won the league III took their hearts
yeah okay forget to sternly they don't
get shoutouts over here at the Rich
Eisen womp gets us this ain't about the
sternly Oliver because now that you're
out of the sternly guy I offered you a
spot in my NFL celebrity League okay and
I've already gotten it I guess I got the
Bella Twins from WWE are you kidding me
you know the billets the Bay of you have
you done oh my god Jerry O'Connell okay
Jerry Ferrara I got all the guy thank
Jerry and your landing at Jerry Cantrell
that's right as David Boreanaz these
kind of Ellen Betances I got a LaDainian
Tomlinson and Terrell Davis
I've got Hall of Famers and you said no
I didn't say no I said how long did I
say no you said no I and I didn't know
got a spot open for you man I mean Stern
doesn't want you I'll tell you how we
want to forget those monkeys over here
at the Stern Show I didn't talk about
these guys I'll talk to you get some
information from a one-seater annulus
for another senior in and we still got
to give me an answer on that League God
can we save in a spot for you make sure
it's ours you should be called the Jerry
League I haven't got any no not even
know three people named Jerry grab some
people named Jerry on my rolodex yeah no
kiddin okay last year was all wide
receivers all wide receivers everybody
was talking about why received how does
it change is it just because guys like
yourself
guys like great Matthew berry guys is it
just the climate or is it is that an
actual thing because I am new although I
am great I am new to fantasy football
does it change here from here why is it
not all Y receivers this year I was
actually not on the wide receiver
bandwagon last year I said that the
running back position was going to have
a revival and it did because you have to
always incorporate regression to the
mean
wide receivers went nuts in 2015
right Allen Robinson went off DeAndre
Hopkins went off of course you have
Antonio Brown Julio Jones Mike in it was
going to decline there was no way they
were going to keep those numbers up
again and what happens they almost all
fell off a cliff
including Hopkins he wasn't even in the
top 30 among wide receivers so now that
running back position has moved up
because you know you got three studs
to top you got david johnson Le'Veon
Bell and Ezekiel Elliott you got some
other young running back Jordan Howard
jje in there
Nevada Freeman has been really
underrated he's been terrific Melvin
Gordon Melvin Gordon I mean he bring out
my plot last year went into sixth round
last year not if not with me where did
you take them maybe the six round I
don't know how to run the numbers on as
low as you went cause he had a fabulous
a some you know I don't know I can't
tell you how to look it up honestly
where I picked Melvin because that's
last year yeah you have to you have to
have tunnel vision you have to be an
average there ain't no feelings and
there ain't no friends when it comes to
finding your boss is true this is true
no flesh in the Bible in the face you
you cherry League the Jerry League
whatever I suppose your hand and then
you know what I want to do it you better
you better be trying to write you better
go talk to man between games don't waste
leave you I'm going to leave with my
friends my family my sister my cousins
I'm always trying to kick their asses
that's just the way it is in fantasy
football second place is the first loser
remember guys place is the first loser
that's right so when you ask me where I
not tell you one thing I won the draft
that I picked Melvin Gordon Melvin
Gordon yeah Melvin Gordon hello first
week yeah yeah hello he was he was
terrific but I think this year what do
you think of Melvin specifically this
year well unfortunately they've already
lost an offensive lineman in the rookie
but they didn't get any running backs in
the offseason this is his job he got
Brandon Oliver basically behind him so
he's a lock first-round pick had a lot
of red zone opportunities last year
double-digit touchdowns and missed some
time at the end of the year too so he
told my Melvin Melvin and um he wound up
he was terrific great he was terrific
yeah human brains own player he was one
of them there's no question about that
so he's now a first-round pick okay but
the wide receiver position I think is
I'm going to move back up a little bit I
think were the guys besides the obvious
if you would who's your first wide
receiver I know it based on the draft I
mean but is it Odell it's a B every year
the guy is you know top three at the
position at worst right Julio is right
there hotels there although you know
Brandon Marshall I agree could be taking
some redzone opportunities away from him
Stanford Evan Engram so random are so
six five he's a
medium red zone drive he's a really good
red zone and anything he's a seasoned
craftsman receiver at this one Brandon
Marshalls like he's like that guy like
he's going to get what he knows the game
so well he knows what he can do what he
can't do he's not going to like you he's
hard to guard yeah you might agree he's
going to give me a red zone so you're
not going to see obj increases numbers I
don't think from last year especially a
touchdown I believe you had 10 AJ Green
yep who was phenomenal before I got hurt
last year Mike Evans who I believe I
traded I turned to Jay a giant it was
like a package thing I got Evans back
from you
I had Aaron Rodgers David Johnson and
Mike Evans the top scoring tile kill
more than anybody want to wait you can
see look at the playoffs there's a lot
of luck involved man I'm not going to
entertain I'd reason is research by the
time you get to that week 16 week 17
your team is totally different from last
year yeah Mike Evans Big Mike
Keyes I have I have like a spot in my
heart for him yeah love him I think he's
gonna have a big guy see Keith if you're
like 6 7 pick eighth pick he's your guy
that's about where he'll go yeah and
they're in the first round and he's
going to show and is it just me or does
famous Jameis Winston look like he lost
about 14 pounds and you know what he can
he can add some serious depth to your
fantasy team because he's not going to
come off the board in one of the first
seven or eight rounds this is a breakout
potential quarterback because you add to
Sean Jackson who can stretch defenses I
mean the Buccaneers barely few the ball
deep last year Jackson one of the best
in terms of making plays down field in
the vertical attack and you've also got
hojae Howard now right I don't know how
much of a fantasy impact is going to
make as a rookie he typically tight ends
they'll make a huge impact Rockies but
he's still another option for famous
Jameis so you could see him move into
the top ten quarterbacks this season do
you think famous will will will uh we'll
take that next step and to become really
great Jameis Winston we're gonna be a
great guy cuz you see flashes of it you
do yeah and you see like the greatness
there but then there's like the
inconsistencies obviously got to get the
turnovers down yeah but the guy means
like I want him to do well because you
know talk about a guy who turns it
around when he was drafted you know what
craziness that he was involved with
in college and the crab lay the whole
whole thing you know he's been a guy
who's been there's been no issues he's a
leader he loves the game you know he's a
voice and and uh you know I want to see
him turn around and be truly like
consistently you know like that dude
he is one of the bigger breakout slash
sleepers although I don't even know if
sleepers exist in fantasy anymore
because everyone knows everything that's
going on it seems right with the players
these days but he's he's got top ten
potential in that offense I mean the
weapons that he has right now the best
he'll have probably in his career I
agree I agree a micro rapport here with
Mike Fabiano it's the Rich Eisen show um
getting wacky over this fantasy stuff
dude I love how energetic you're getting
here throw on your coat and everything
where is my coat did we start the
segment with a coat on I can't remember
who did yeah it might be behind the desk
bro
who needs it yeah do you look good man
you look good
whoa what kind of what is your shirt is
it cotton tri-blend I think the kind
that look like a prawn okay what do they
make the Abercrombie shirts up okay this
is this is a Italian linen it is no
animals died making it futsal is yeah
cause it's a little harder to plant base
fabric yeah I don't know if that offends
you because I know a lot of people have
offended my dad nah man I'm good I'm
good are we talking about Jameis I more
offended that you didn't accept my
invitation yet that's what offends me
everybody wants to dance with the dingo
everybody wants a piece of me I got it I
got a bunch of superstars in this legal
[ __ ] running up the final watch and all
in your league like they do they want
Rapaport in the leakers oh they'll take
you come on man I got you guys out to be
in a league where you're talking trash
every single we had winning one will see
if I would take them off you have to let
a lot of talk in here get in the league
and we'll see if you win let me tell you
something our trash talk I'm like all
right anybody could talk trash when they
win it takes a real pro real high-level
Hall of Fame trash talker to do it when
they're on their hands and knees that's
the kid and that's what around my
business when I'm losing
yeah is easy because I win so much I
kind of like eyes like if you get my
back against the wall and I'm losing
like you could be
but halftime of a game at the four
o'clock games I'm gonna call your house
and the one thing my prerequisite about
being in English I need your home phone
your cell phone number I'm not a man
you're gonna hear the tone of my voice
yeah all right I don't know I'm ruining
your weekend I don't know if the MS and
The Bella Twins are gonna be taking your
phone calls on Sundays but we'll see the
Miz knows me he's a good man yeah I
don't care what he is we fight jointly I
don't care what he is
I don't care about to elbow drama be in
Cantrell's league this year and by the
way Mizer's never beaten me in a fantasy
matchup ever I'll beat it that's why
them okay tell them quarterbacks
yeah is there anything other than Aaron
Rodgers and Tom Brady that you would go
to earlier than the third or fourth
round I mean would you would it be crazy
to pick Aaron Rodgers late in the third
round
I know it's every year I just know I
can't do it there's too many good
quarterbacks out there that you would
get Prescott I didn't mean draft him
Matt Ryan was a late round pick or a
waiver wire pickup second best player in
fantasy football based on points I can't
to omit it's run like in Jerry's league
last year Cantrell because we're talking
about so many Jerry's I think you fell
in the fifth round that I said at that
point I'm taking them but I can't do it
man I need court I need running backs
and wide receivers I mean quarterbacks
late you know how many top-ten
quarterbacks you can get after around 10
10 Aparna okay a ton of them bro
will you stay around for another segment
of course okay for you anything all
right I want you in that league all
right what's the earliest you would ever
take what dinkar do you know you don't
mention how good I look in this jackets
a little big though
hey look good look sharp yeah what's it
made out of I can't reveal Gary
checkers and defenses you wait that
that's what you do how wait how much
ground rounds man a good kicker can help
you win the Justin Tucker Stephen
Gostkowski but there's so many guys that
come out of those two positions and
defenses that come out of nowhere who
end up being good starters or maybe you
just stream the position as well
dude I weigh on those positions never
draft them before the last two runs if I
draft one at all I might wait pick them
up off the waiver wire defense ain't a
kicker you're crazy man why have you
ever won a league why I've won a few my
friends I've won
like you know I gotta you another man
you know I got a target on you I'm gonna
put a star on x2 certain people I gonna
run over you like that guy could truck
hey it's like I'm the one who invited
you to the league and you're the one who
said no you want that dance let's do it
man yeah let's dance
brother I think he's in you want that
dance oh hey let's do it man I'll hold
you nice oh yeah I hold you need do you
lead
oh I'm leo yeah I need to dance you
won't be leading in the fantasy league
like that right now and I'll be talking
in your ear the whole time is that too
fast Mike you want to do a two-step
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
all right we are back Michael Fabiano
Mikey fab nfl.com senior fantasy analyst
I am filling in for Rich Eisen Michael
Rapaport NFL senior guest host um
talking all fantasy everything that
fantasy is real there's no friends at
fantasy there's no feelings in fantasy
football Jay Cutler is now the starting
quarterback for the Miami Dolphins I
truly believe that the real winner here
is the Fox Sports broadcasting the fact
that you don't have your lid yeah I mean
you're almost gonna do I think he'll do
better than I imagined a Cutler gonna is
gonna do I think he'll be fine he's got
a good easy way about him and he's got
Jimmy Nance - Jimmy's the best so yeah I
think he'll do good I think I don't know
why they gave color that job anyway
obviously he didn't want to be there but
when you hear him speak at his press
coverage and you see you hear him talk
after his first practice you're like why
did how did he get the job he's got good
hair though he's got good hair and well
you know where's the Los Angeles you
there's a lot of people like good you
know it's got good air Steve Smith
senior definitely I want to be calling
games yeah I know he's watching it but I
love that guy talk about trash-talking
extraordinaire but as a football player
and as a fantasy football player which
is more important Jay Cutler Colin
Kaepernick is still somewhere mowing his
lawn okay and doing good things in the
community okay what do you think of
Colin Kaepernick chances of getting into
the NFL and what do you think of jay
color being signed by the Miami Dolphins
ah in terms of color he's probably a QB
- at best he did have a very good season
with Adam GaSe when they were in Chicago
together you know he's 76 now I was 2015
but okay it was all saying things it was
also better on the field than it was in
the statutes because he had a career
best in completion percentage but he was
the 20th best quarterback in fantasy
football which is not all that great so
you're probably takin them late if
you're taking them at all lot of leagues
now that you have like this super Flex
position to QB leagues he'll definitely
be drafted ten team leagues probably not
for Kapernick whether or not he gets it
in the league doesn't matter from a
fantasy perspective if he's a starting
quarterback then you're looking at him
he was good lad he really was weak
stretch where he scored 19 or more
fantasy points he had 20 or more points
in two of those games I think had over
30 in a game against Miami all because
it's nothing it's a great thrower of the
football but he can run man and that's
why guys like deshaun Watson and Deshawn
Kaiser they kind of intrigued me in
dynasty leagues because they can run
with a football dak Prescott rushed for
six touchdowns last year that was big
from a fantasy perspective so he's
running quarterbacks like a guy Tim
Tebow was a good fantasy quarterback
when he played
I had Tim Tebow it didn't matter that he
couldn't throw the ball because he gave
you ten points a game just from running
it when you had to Tebow did you win
that league I did win a league with Tim
Tebow believe it or not I did I want to
lead 77 leagues
I'm gonna win one Knutson I want to
leave with Matt Moore believe it or not
a few years ago and Billy Bullock you
remember Billy Bo'ness yeah dude that's
that's how far I go back in these
leagues when we stay away from 2017-2018
season we were guys that you're like ah
Andrew Luck right now with that shoulder
I you're hearing rumblings that you
might miss regular season games that
scares me especially because his price
tag is going to be right around where
Drew Brees is going right so fifth sixth
round at this point he worries me I
never say never if Andrew Luck falls for
the ninth round I'm probably going to
take a chance on him
Mark Ingram scares me because Adrian
Peterson is there now this is a guy who
41% of his fantasy points came in like
four games last year now you've got a
future hall-of-famer in the backend
what's the word on Peterson in training
camp everything you read
he looks good and the team there was
some quotes from the team boy he looks
fantastic in offseason a lot of ancient
armies you know I mean that guy we want
to what talk about a physique he's
ridiculous he's ridiculous yeah where
they seen him cut to the left cut to the
right hey you know I just kind of move
like good death like that I've seen it
got that it's quick it's probably
quicker than you might be probably
quicker than you think but there's going
to be a committee there right yeah
Ingram wasn't our big
good for him though at this point is
career AP not good from a fantasy yes I
agree
anyway she is another guy I'm a little
down on right two years in a row I know
he's got the good yards per carry
average yards active contact a solid but
Thomas Rawls is still there and he's
looked good in camping celty they've got
CJ Prosise as well you're going to see a
lot of committees this year that are
going to make you want to pull your hair
out if you're trying to start these guys
from a fantasy standpoint especially
with this influx of rookie running backs
that's come in this class was ridiculous
I can't remember a season where so many
fantasy fans and analysts were so into
these rookie running back Leonard
fournette Christian McCaffrey Dalvin
cook so number one guy in Minnesota Joe
Mixon Kareem hunt is a huge sleeper
people talk about Jamal Williams and Joe
Webb's there's so many rookie running
back so people are high on who's the
best of that bunch you have to go for
net you have to I mean this guy fourth
overall pick they didn't draft them to
sit on him it does barone you want to
run the football number one you know you
play the the clock management game
number two you take the ball out of
Blake bortles his hands and Keaton firm
throwing interceptions because that's a
big problem for that kid no kidding big
problem okay I know it's crazy he's been
a top ten fantasy quarterback the last
two years in a row last year was my
quarterback scoring might need to be
changed the year before was good last
year was a discount still finished in
the top ten garbage time man yeah I know
he's great he's great garbage cutting
good garbage checks a guy last year or I
didn't have him but I loved him I loved
watching my love his store and I love
the way he runs on time Montgomery who
was a former receiver and now he's a
true blue running back had a great
season Green Bay
they got Marty be out there they got a
rod he's sick what do you think of time
Montgomery probably going to end up
being the third or fourth round pick I
dropped him as an RB 2 and PPR leagues
and in standard pick him as an RB 2 yes
I agree I would here's the the pros with
him right Aaron Rodgers is the
quarterback how many stack fronts are
you going to see none right no you can't
Rogers will kill you he's a pass catcher
so he's 2-dimensional right he needs to
work on his pass protection we'll see if
she gets those bold line opportunities
because Jamal Williams is in there as
well but
as a pass catcher you can get maybe 40
receptions out of them definitely over a
thousand scrimmage yards and in that
explosive offense they've got Montgomery
could be very good this year and
Martellus Bennett yeah
Marcello's Bennett tighten tighten
position is taking a hit but going into
last year we all thought oh Italians now
it's kind of taking his why is that so
well because Tyler Eifert can't stay
healthy right Gronkowski's coming off an
injury Jordan Reed can't stay he'll
right Jimmy grim although he's lost like
you 20 pounds he looks good he's going
to do good he looks good Delaney's 47
you but you saw some tight ends that we
thought were going to perform well
Lasher who didn't like a Coby Fleener
for example you've got two good tight
ends in Los Angeles with the Chargers
Antonio Gates and hundred Henry the
opposition is taking a hit to the point
where now you can draft a guy like Zach
Ertz really late if you don't get a
grant or you don't get a read or you
don't get a Kelsie's how early would you
pick Gronk I'd probably say right around
the turn of the second and third round
are you crap dude they're dying the guy
good buddy head and shoulders above
everybody else that position every time
you know what he isn't either risky yes
at what point in Draft does Gronkowski
fall where you take him fifth fifth
round yeah I won't be there I know he
won't beat it well I think one cause as
much as I love him as much as I respect
him as much that can't stand the
Patriots did the injury factor I mean
he's going to kick but he's going to
give it as much as he takes it he's
going to put up points is going to put
up numbers he's good for real fantasy
he's good for real football but I can't
take him sick right now if you want him
that's where he's going to go anybody
report those feelings manatee apparently
he's having a bad camp
wykowski I've just seen reports WEEI
they're saying that he's had a lesson
stutter candy doesn't look like
Gronkowski yeah I don't know that's
something to watch because if those
reports continue he might fall into the
third or fourth round okay we did a poll
this wasn't the poll real quickly Mike
before I let you go you have a spelling
bee okay
you got Jay Cutler you got Rob
Gronkowski got Michael Rapaport no
feelings who do you think would win a
spelling bee jay color Rob Gronkowski
Michael Rapaport come on I'm going color
I'm going taller fine all right you got
a spell Cutler yes Michael reporter Rob
Gronkowski cuz I know Rob Gronkowski
would probably be like zu t le are how
about color Kristin Cavallari how do you
spell her name no clue I don't know I
don't want to learn it phone I don't
want to divide it will any man have the
right color just one no I don't I don't
spell anybody anybody else's wife
Michael Fabiano listen I'm gonna do a
little plug for myself I told you that I
was a senior annulus analyst okay that's
how many words if I mispronounce this is
a segment analyst I said I'm always good
man
several you ain't going an annual
analyst listen the Gillette Stadium the
Grunk well Michael Rapaport August 20th
fantasy sports that's well I am going
now I'm walking into the terror dome
live podcast mock draft dress mock draft
you could get tickets to dance with the
dingo me Jim Breuer Matthew berry he
knows all my fantasy football prowess
Trey Wingo I want to take a shot at him
this year Jim brewer and the croc
Gillette Stadium you could get tickets
fantasy sports fest dance with the dingo
calm you're welcome to come you're a
very busy man
cameraman yeah gonna be fabricated
honest around going to Boston tomorrow I
got an event in st. Louis with the
Cardinals with Adam Wainwright big
league impact which is a huge so I'll be
bouncing around all over that sounds
like a lot of fun it's gonna be funny
you know a lot of Gronkowski you know if
he's if he's good I'm gonna okay make
sure he's healthy I'll give up I'll give
him a full physical
and I'll also challenge them to a
spelling bee live August 20th yeah
Michael Fabiano senior nfl.com analyst
senior to senior thanks for taking the
time got it are you I got welcomed in on
every five hours left sorry 34 and a
half we're going to text Rich Eisen
Michael Rapaport guest Olson my man
Michael Fabiano stay with us we're
talking more fantasy more sports more
life more love and we can do some
spelling bee questions when we return
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country
and audience if you liked that video be
sure to download our app and I'll be
sure to move week six games to Saturday
for that wedding you have to go to